die machen jetzt hier in berlin war es
die sagen im grunde sollen sich alle
kinder jetzt anstecken in den schulen
denn man kann sowieso nicht mehr
aufhalten und immer an die schulen dicht
macht dann lässt man es halt einfach
laufen ist das in deinen augen der
richtige weg das ist ja nicht viel
weniger als eine revolution eigentlich
absolut ich finds gut ich unterstütze
diese revolution und ich hoffe und
drücke dem man dem zugehört haben alle
daumen dass sie erfolgreich ist ich
diese ganzen die kinder ist sozusagen
von von der bildung abzuschneiden ist
ein so überragende ein überragender
eingriff in ein grundrecht dass ich
schon seit wochen und monaten der
meinung bin dafür fehlt jegliche
grundlage die argumente sind genannt
worden kinder erkranken
wenn sie erkranken nicht schlimm
diese phobie ein kind des erkranktes
trifft dann irgendwann oma opa erkrankt
oma stirbt dann ist im grunde behoben
weil in den gehobenen altersschichten
ein hoher impf grad vorhanden ist ich
sehe überhaupt keine veranlassung nicht
auf normal zu schalten und ich finde den
einen gedanken interessant den wir auch
in anderen kontexten diskutieren was
machen wir dann mit den kindern die
durch sorge haben müssen wegen
vorerkrankungen und da kommen wir wieder
zu einem ganz finde ich bezeichneten
punkt die können meiner meinung nach
ihrer schulpflicht nachkommen von zu
haus aus indem sie sich einfach in den
klassenraum zu schalten also jemanden
wie viele menschen schalten sich
inzwischen über teams und zoom und
andere plattformen irgendwo zu das muss
ja auch im klassenraum möglich sein und
glücklich hat man die gesamte klasse
beieinander und es kann nicht sein dass
rückständigkeit in der digitalisierung
plus eine hyperventilierenden helikopter
eltern dazu führen dass kinder nicht in
die schule gehen können also für mich
wäre in georgia ventilieren die lehrer
dass wir es für
mich wichtig ich habe in mir zuckt da
irgendwie und ich überlege die ganze
zeit ob es ein argument gibt zwischen
krankenhauspersonal das gang
hauspersonal und lehrer verbindet und
das argument liegt ja auf der hand sie
haben beide unmittelbar mit
schutzbefohlenen zu tun und ich würde
hierdurch sehr stark für eine
impfpflicht plädieren und ich würde auch
sagen wer sich dann nicht impfen lässt
kann den lehrerberuf eben nicht ausüben
so wie jemand wir haben es vorhin vom
hamburger erste bürgermeister gehört so
wie jemand der im krankenhaus sagt also
eine hepatitis impfung mache ich nicht
kann halt nicht gang hausarzt sein
[Musik]